I I don't think that there is a single
person who I would identify I think
there are many people whose ideas in
various areas of human endeavor who I
really admire I would say one of them is
Kwame Anthony Appiah who's a faculty
member at Princeton who has written I
think quite brilliantly about an issue
that I think is extraordinarily
important which is the nature of
identity and how how we translate our
national identities our ethnic
identities are religious identities into
living in a cosmopolitan world so there
is someone who is a philosopher who I
greatly admire it doesn't me the measure
of a good life is what you are able to
achieve with the gifts that you've been
handed and how well you have treated
those around you